(upbeat hiphop music)
- So, welcome to another
episode of the "Addy Hour".
Today, I'm honored to be
able to host co-founder
of March for Our Lives, David Hogg.
And today we're gonna be
jumping into a conversation
really talking about activism,
self care, and ending gun violence.
Now, I know for those
of you in the audience,
a lot of you are probably
familiar with David,
you're familiar with his
work and his efforts.
And I think today it will be nice
to really peel back a
little bit and talk about
some of the things that
he's been involved in,
some of his goals, but
also about him as a person,
and some of the things that
he's really trying to elevate
in terms of really
making sure that the work
that others are doing on the ground
in a lot of ways is also
highlighted as well.
So, really excited to jump
into this conversation.
Obviously, David is someone
who is thrust into activism
following the tragic
and unfortunate shooting
at his high school in
Parkland, Florida in 2018.
And from that event, he and his
classmates have really vowed
to be change makers in a lot of ways.
And he's resolved that
no other young person
should have to experience the
tragic impact of violence,
of gun violence in particular.
So, as I mentioned,
he's the co-founder of
March for Our Lives.
They've been involved in
lots of different initiatives
over the years.
Just to highlight a few;
the march they had in Washington, DC,
where he spoke to an
estimated 800,000 protesters.
He and his sister,
Lauren are also authors,
they co-authored "Never again",
which became a New York
Times' bestselling book.
They also contributed to the book,
"Glimmer of Hope: How
Tragedy Sparked a Movement."
And they'd been involved in
lots of different efforts
over the years, touring
across the country,
really meeting families and individuals,
who've had losses at the
hands of gun violence,
and just also educating themselves
about ways to really make an impact.
David's also someone
who has a pretty large
social media following,
and he really uses his platform
to promote civic engagement,
activism, and voting.
So again, just grateful to have David here
on the "Addy Hour" episode today.
David, thanks so much for
taking the time to join us.
- Yeah, thanks for having me on.
- Of course.
So again, a lot of people know about you,
maybe not know a lot about
you on the personal level,
but one of the things
that I really like to do
on this program too, is always
just to check in with folks.
I think is important to remind people
that you're also a student.
So, in the middle of all
this work that you're doing,
you've also been taking classes,
you're coming to the end of the semester.
So, I actually just wanted to start out
and see how things are with you these days
in the midst of everything
that's going on in the world,
you know, as you're
wrapping up the semester,
just in your daily life, how
are you doing these days?
- Yeah, I would say I'm pretty good.
Just trying to figure out,
I dunno, it's kinda weird,
'cause when you take time
off of school or work,
I think a lot of people have
this feeling where it's like,
you don't have things to be
stressed out about anymore,
but you still have this
stress for some reason,
you know?
- Hm.
- So I've been dealing with that.
And I've just been thinking a lot more
about what I want to do in the future,
just because I'm now halfway
through my four years of college,
and thinking about different
opportunities and stuff,
internships and things to do.
Even though I really, honestly,
I wish I could just take time
off and like not do anything
for a minute because it's...
I think my generation, especially,
but pretty much Americans in general
have an arguably unhealthy obsession
with doing as much as possible,
and don't really value spending
time with friends and family
as much as I think we should,
'cause we think in a very,
almost like hyper capitalistic manner
that can really kinda hurt
a lot of our friendships,
relationships, and our
family relationships overall.
Although, I think a lot
of us have been able
to spend more time this year
with our families and everything,
for some of us perhaps too much.
(Addy laughs)
I think I'm doing pretty good overall,
just trying to be more accepting
of not necessarily knowing what
I'm gonna do in the future,
even though I know it'd be
something vaguely political,
or communications or whatever.
Being more accepting of the
unknown and kind of embracing it
and taking care of myself
while I'm doing that.
- Right, right, well, I
appreciate your honesty in that.
And I think that's really
healthy in a lot of ways too.
But I think it's good that
you're being honest with yourself
and also highlighting the tension
between all the work
that needs to be done,
but then also knowing that,
it's still good to slow down,
and spend time with family and friends,
but there's not always an easy answer.
So I think, just even the fact
that you're verbalizing it.
So, I think for a lot of
us, sometimes it's easy,
like you said, not to verbalize it,
and just go kind of 1000 miles an hour,
and now even taking
that time to pull back.
I mean, on that note
too, you all have been,
I mean, I think, part of it is just
because you all have been so...
It isn't based in the
culture, like you said,
but all the important work
you all have been doing
over the last three years.
So, just to kinda pull back a little bit,
what's that been like would you say
for the last few years being David Hogg.
I know that sounds like a cheesy question,
but I really just wanted
to kinda get a sense,
or a capturing of what that
journey has been like for you.
- I mean, it's certainly
had its ups and its downs.
I would say that it's been really amazing
to see how my friends and I are able
to take an idea like doing
a March on Washington,
or talking about youth voting,
and really help turn it into reality.
Although, we were by no
means the only people
that talked about youth
voting, for example.
It's been incredible to see
the achievements we've had
even in the past three years,
with one of the highest
youth voter turnouts in 2018,
on any non-presidential midterm.
And really the highest youth voter turnout
in American history in 2020,
it's pretty remarkable.
So I think those are some of high points.
I think some of the lower ones though are,
as I kinda talked about earlier
that on unhealthy obsession,
like hyper capitalistic
obsession with productivity
and like, that being the
only thing that matters,
paired with the trauma
and survivor's guilt
of going through shooting, and
talking to all these people
that have experienced gun
violence on a daily basis,
literally, probably, tens
of thousands of people
at this point.
The tearing of those two things
is a really dangerous combination
that I've seen hurt a lot of people
that I know that have worked in,
what I would call the
peace advocacy space.
Because the work that
we do is very important,
but sometimes because it is so important,
we lose sight of how important we are
and the importance of taking
care of ourselves in this,
because of that guilt,
because of that PTSD,
and that trauma, that
trauma-driven response.
I think I've certainly had
my own challenges with that.
Not just because of like notoriety,
or attention, or whatever.
Much of which, quite frankly,
is because Parkland is a
predominantly white community
that's more affluent than
the average community.
But it's also because
I share a lot of that
unhealthy obsession with productivity
and I for the longest time,
I just really liked it,
the work that we were
doing, like a campaign,
I thought in 2018 we're just
gonna work 36 hours a day,
basically, every single day
and not stop for anything.
I mean, literally, work oftentimes
until we got physically sick
to the point that we
couldn't work anymore,
which happened multiple times to me,
and I know happened to
others that we worked with.
But it's really taken
me broadening that view
and realizing that my self-care
and hanging out with friends
and talking to people, isn't
something to feel guilty about.
It's something that's a necessity.
It's part of my productivity.
Cause this is not like
a campaign where it's
a sprint, you have November 3rd
or whatever day it is that
you're gonna finish by.
We don't know when gun
violence is gonna end.
It's much more accustomed
to an ultra marathon
where we don't know the
ultimate destination
and there's a lot of wrong
paths we can go down.
So we really have to pace ourselves
and be even prepared to pass on the Baton
to the next generation,
although, I hope that's not necessary.
So it's been a lot over
the past three years,
it's felt like a lifetime.
So much travel, so many
people that I've met,
so many experiences, and I
really had to challenge myself
to figure out how to prioritize myself
and kinda putting on my oxygen mask first,
before I can help anyone else.
And it's difficult when
we have this obsession
with constant achievement
and constantly doing
more, and more, and more, and more,
and being obsessed with productivity
instead of realizing the importance of,
and it sounds super cliche,
and I kinda hate the term,
but like taking care of yourself.
'Cause we hear it all the time
but I never really
understood what that meant
until the past year or two.
But because of that, I've really been able
to take care of myself
and to take a step back
and think about how do
I wanna enter this space
instead of what are all the
holes that I need to fill in.
So that's kind of what the
past three years had been like.
I actually struggled a lot with PTSD,
not just from the shooting,
but actually from activism
in the threats and the harassment
in even how hard we were working at times;
like getting four hours
sleep oftentimes, you know,
every day for a month or two
is not, it's not healthy.
Especially, when you're a younger person
and you need a lot of sleep.
And then you have to go in
front of people and talk,
and then you have to go
on the news and stuff.
And you're concerned that, are
you taking up too much space,
how do you uplift people properly,
but not in a tokenistic banner,
but how do you like still highlight
the issues that's going on?
And, luckily because, you know,
going to therapy for basically
the past year and a half,
I've really been able to
start focusing much more
on taking care of myself and consistently,
checking my bases every day
of like, it seems ridiculous,
but just eating, drinking,
getting enough sleep,
and focusing on those basic core things,
it's all I can really start
to build that, you know,
on top of that foundation
to become more productive,
but in a healthy manner.
- Yeah, yeah, I think that's so important.
I mean, I think there's a
lot of maturity there too
and growth along the way.
And that, not to sound that you
weren't mature early on too,
but just even the way that
you kind of characterize
like you were going a
thousand miles an hour
at the beginning, then you're realizing
where you need to pull back,
where you need to have that self care.
But, I imagine that's still not easy,
because in some ways I think
that's what beats a cycle.
'Cause you know, the less
sleep, the more work you do,
the more outcome, and the
more output you can see.
So I'm curious, like how
did you move along that?
'Cause in some ways it's almost like
you had to sacrifice some of the work
to be able to take care of yourself.
And you talked about having
that long-term trajectory.
I'd imagine that's still a
tension 'cause it's like,
"Well, I'm not doing this
work, I'm pulling back.
So X, Y, and Z is not getting done."
So how have you reconciled
that in your mind?
- I think the main way
I would've reconciled it
is realizing that
I think, 'cause we have a
very individualistic culture,
we have a tendency to
get very self-absorbed
in the work that we do and think that
we're the only person doing the work.
I think that applies
to all of us, honestly,
because we're all the stars
of our own reality, TV shows,
in some sense, in our mind.
I think what it took me realizing was
it was truly effectively delegating
and working to hire people
that were actually qualified
to do this work, had
experience doing this work
in the nonprofit space,
and organizing stuff to help do the work
within March for Our Lives,
or the organization is basically grown,
over like basically eight
times, over the past two years
in terms of our total number of staff.
'Cause we were woefully understaffed,
and had a severe lack
of experience, honestly,
with a lot of the work that we are doing
and it's still youth-led,
but we have people that
have more experience,
helping execute the
plans that young people
ultimately come up with
in the first place.
So that's been the most
effective thing is like
hiring other people to do the work
that I didn't necessarily
need to be doing myself,
but I just found myself
doing a lot of the time,
and then just preoccupying
myself with school, 'cause it's,
as you can imagine, going go into college
and traveling every weekend
and going on like it's just,
I kind of had to realize that
there some sacrifices involved
in order for me to prioritize
really what's best for my future,
and that's going to
college instead of just,
necessarily doing a ton of
work every day in this field
that in some ways it's
also just exhausting.
It's activism and a lot of the times
it's a really thankless
job and it's difficult
because you can believe that,
even if you do achieve these things
that somehow it's gonna like make up
for that lack of self care,
but it doesn't, it really doesn't.
So yeah, it's been difficult
making those decisions,
but you kinda have to
learn how to say, no,
a lot of the time, even though it's hard
and it feels like you're, you
know, it almost feels like...
'Cause we're told so often
about how important it is
to take every opportunity,
it kinda feels like you're
cutting off your right arm,
for lack of a better word.
But you have to realize that,
even if it does feel that way,
ultimately, you have to be able to survive
and focus on What's really important,
and in my case that's school.
And it's also the work that
March for Our Lives does,
that doesn't get on the
news, focusing on mutual aid,
focusing on, the different aspects
of racial and economic justice
that plays into ending gun violence,
and stopping people from
wanting to pick up a gun
in the first place, instead
of just talking about
how they get the gun.
We have to have a holistic
solution here that we talk about.
And those conversations,
unfortunately are things
that are great to fit in sound bites,
are great to put on the
news for a lot of people.
'Cause they don't wanna talk
about the lack of resources
that causes the community to,
you know, that results in violence,
and historic, and systemic injustice.
But that's the work that we're doing
and it hasn't been an easy transition,
but I've just realized, I
have to take care of myself,
and focus on what's ahead
with school, and yeah.
I've been working on
a couple of cool projects at school too.
There's a public opinion polling project
that I worked on this semester for youth.
So yeah, that was cool.
- Yeah, I mean a lot of ways,
it sounds like you're letting yourself
ride that tension too.
'Cause there's so much
work that has to be done.
I mean, even as I'm listening
to you talking you talking,
I'm sure it was probably hits you too.
Like, I mean that's a amount of work
that you're talking about
and that's not something
that anyone would be able to
do if they're spread too thin.
But at the same time-
- Great,
considering what they can do themselves.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, would you say that you all have,
as a group have people bought
into this idea of self-care,
or has it been certain pockets
of people, like how has that?
'Cause I'm just thinking about, you know,
I'm imagining what the vibe
was like when you all started,
how much energy there must've been,
as you all were touring
across the country.
But I'm curious if that shift
is kinda pervaded, commercialized,
or do you think it's in pockets?
- I think it's in pockets,
I think it's more like...
I think a lot of the time,
especially, the young people
that were involved in the
beginning, myself included,
but especially, for
some of the other people
that weren't as privileged as
me to have the power of being
not only being a guy, but also
being a white straight guy
in the first place like, inherently,
it's gonna be a lot easier for
me to exist in these spaces
than a lot of other
co-founders that were women,
or non-binary or were LGBTQ, or whatever.
And for a lot of them they understand
they just got exhausted
and weren't accepting
of the space that wasn't, you know,
which is really difficult
for them to function in,
because young people are
important with HR experience,
unfortunately.
And in a youth-led organization I'll say
the reason why March for Our
Lives has been successful
is because it is youth-led,
but it's also that very
same youth-led energy
that can also end the organization
because it's the combination
of a lot of energy
and kind of adhocracy paired
with a lack of experience,
to be honest, it can be really damaging.
So a lot of the, one
of the co-founders of,
taken a step back, which I think is fine,
I think we see that
throughout these movements.
There are people that take years off
at times and step back in.
And honestly, even if
some of the co-founders
don't ever wanna do this work again,
they've done more than
99.9% of people will ever do
in their lives around this issue.
So I'm forever thankful for that.
And I can't blame them,
'cause ultimately, I want them alive.
That's what it comes down to,
'cause this work is really,
it's really hard for these young people.
So I think a lot of
like myself were forced
to learn about self care
by, to use a metaphor,
kind of like, you can tell
someone to not put their hand
on a hot stove a lot of times,
but sometimes it takes getting burned
to really realize the
importance of not doing that,
and I think that may be the case,
no, I don't mean to generalize,
but I think it as the case
with a lot of young people.
Especially, traumatized young people
that care so much
understandably about this issue.
But yeah, so a lot of the co-founders
have taken a step back
to focus on the arts,
focus on theater, focus on college,
which is totally valid,
and I'm never gonna blame them for that.
But I think as an organization,
we've gotten a lot better
at focusing on that self-care aspect.
We do a lot more workshops
and trainings around it and stuff now.
But unfortunately, when it is young people
there is some element of
needing to learn it the hard way
at least in my case.
'Cause I can't tell you how
many times I was told to,
you know, "Make sure you're
taking care of yourself."
And I didn't understand,
I always heard that,
but I didn't understand
what that looked like for me
until I really sat down,
and started to kind of get reconnected
with my emotions, and my
experiences, and stuff.
Because I think, especially with guys,
I know that I had a
tendency in the beginning
to just shut out all
the emotions and trauma,
secondhand trauma that I
was hearing about every day
of people having their loved ones shot,
having even their pets
shot in front of them,
horrible stuff.
And just like kind of
like blocking it out,
which I thought was the best
we way of dealing with it
but it actually just piles up.
And I actually found myself,
I thought the PTSD and
the trauma and stuff
from activism, from obviously,
the shooting and stuff,
was just something that would make me sad,
and that's how I would know.
But I didn't realize it just made me numb,
I didn't feel anything
for the longest time,
which was really concerning.
It got to the point
where every conversation
I heard was about gun violence.
'Cause I was talking so
little to any of my friends
about anything else, 'cause
the work just became our life.
And what it took for me
was really sitting down
and journaling every
day to get back in touch
with my emotions and to process
what that had gone through
in the past year, going
to therapy and stuff
to understand that those emotions
are things that I have to
cope with as anyone else does,
and it's not just something
that you can just block out.
So that's been a lot of my journey around
the self-care aspect and
the co-founders as well,
and other students, but I'd be
lying if I said it was easy,
and there weren't people that are hurt,
not necessarily by any fault
of their own, but just by,
you know, we're trying to do
the work of a government here,
essentially, because our
government is not doing this work.
And that's not what we're supposed to do.
We're supposed to have elected them,
we're supposed to be college students,
or high school students.
We have elected officials
that are supposed to
represent us for a reason,
and it's exactly so we
shouldn't have to do this.
- Yeah, that's so that's so important.
I mean, you've hit on so many
important pieces there too,
but I mean, I think I can just...
It seems like you've really
gotten into a good place
of just realizing a lot of these things.
I mean, kind of the self-reflection,
even as you're talking
about the journaling,
that you're all doing more
work than you should be doing,
and just all the weight
that comes with that.
'Cause even as you were talking about,
all the families that
you've interacted with
across the country,
I can meet in my mind
what's going to like,
I mean, all those
conversations are weighty,
and in some ways I feel
like you must have,
even if he didn't know,
been carrying all that.
'Cause those stories you hear
them over and over again,
but they're gonna penetrate at some point.
I mean, it seems like a
lot of the ways you're able
to kinda channel that energy
into the increased activism,
then still you have your own story,
you have all these stories
that you're carrying with you,
and so really having a
place to process that
I think is really important.
It sounds like that's
been kind of a weekly,
daily process for you as of late,
just making sure that you
have the space for that,
which I think is critical,
but not always easy to acknowledge
in the heat of the moment, in the sense,
when you're in the middle of the work.
- Yeah, I think it goes,
it's all so important to deal
with that self care aspect,
because I have seen so
many times how in activism,
I would be lying, if I said
it wasn't traumatizing work
for a lot of young
people, including myself,
like, getting called
by people with AR-15s,
getting screamed at by them,
having your house swatted,
death threats that I get,
but also a lot of kids that
work in the organization
and in the gun violence
prevention movement,
and people to in general get that trauma,
and that exhaustion can end
up turning us on each other.
'Cause we start to think the reason
why we're not being successful
is because of people
that we're working with,
when in reality, it's because, you know,
you can say activism isn't easy,
or social change isn't easy,
but it is really, really hard.
And it may not necessarily
be because of anybody's fault
that you work with, but you
can start to turn on each other
when you're not taking care of yourselves,
which I think is a major problem that,
not just the peace advocacy space has,
but also a problem that social
movements have in general,
because the work that we do
really is incredibly important.
But when we're not
taking care of ourselves,
we can have a tendency
to turn on each other,
and get really negative and act
horribly towards each other.
And if you don't select times,
on a regular basis to really sit down
and talk those things out, it piles up,
and it really starts hurting people.
- Yeah, yeah, I heard,
so important that you all
are paying attention to that.
So I mean, even, all the things
that you all have been through,
I mean, just in general,
when people have gone through
that as you know, I mean,
it has an effect on
people's day-to-day lives,
just in terms of like,
schoolwork in general,
can they still focus as well?
Then you add on all the
activism work that you're doing,
which has a whole nother heightened level
of importance, intention,
and just weight to it,
and you put all that together.
So I think, yeah, that's
been at the forefront,
recently in other ways.
I was thinking back to
one of the interviews
you and your sister did to, you know,
one of the things you talked
about reminded me of that.
Just when you all were talking about
how the activism was
your therapy, in a sense.
And it seems like what
you've been talking about
ways that you're able
to kind of channel that
and use that as a way to cope.
Do you think that was effective
and helpful in some ways,
I mean, you've kind of
talked about the ways
where some things were ignored,
but you didn't pay as much
attention necessarily,
to some of the self-care
as you could have.
But what would you say
are some of the positives
of what you're doing and the activism,
the how that affected you all as people?
- I mean, I actually think sometimes
that like massive marches
and demonstrations,
even if not directly
politically impactful,
or something like that, I think,
it can actually be really
beneficial in some ways
because people realize they're not alone.
And I think that's been
one of the biggest benefits
that we've seen a lot of social
movements from, you know,
feminist movements historically speaking,
to civil rights, to to
peace, to anti-war movements,
in some ways they're almost like massive,
it's certainly not
certified as group therapy,
but in some ways it's kind of
like a massive venting session
that I think actually can be
really helpful for people.
I think the issue comes when
those individuals continue
to focus so much on
that and sacrifice stuff
to try to end things that
are causing this trauma
that they end up throwing
away, the things that they love
and the people that they
love, not throwing them away.
Throwing them away is too hard of a word,
but not prioritizing them
just as much as the work.
And that ends up making
them feel really resentful,
towards the movement,
towards the people that they work with,
because they feel like
they've sacrificed so much,
and there's been so little progress.
Which honestly, there's
been a lot of progress
in terms of the historical perspective
in gun violence prevention,
but on the scale that we needed at,
it's been very little, unfortunately.
But I think, the activism
in some ways done properly
can be a form of therapy,
but done in a way that causes
harm, or done in a way that,
where you're not taking care of yourself
can be a form of trauma.
When you're throwing away
the things that you love,
and just working on it every single day,
and there's no end in sight
of when it's gonna stop.
So yeah, that would be my
main way of thinking about it.
- Yeah, and I think that's
a really good point.
I mean, the group therapy
piece in particular,
I mean, I think, there's a lot to that.
'Cause there's that
common lived experience
that you all have, so that
you can support each other,
and talking to someone who understands it.
- Yeah, and there's a
lot of power in that,
because we feel like we're
surrounded, you know,
when you're around 800,000 people,
even if not all of them have
been affected by gun violence,
a lot of them have been.
Like at the March, for example,
those people see each other,
and they see that they're not alone.
And I actually think that's a
huge amount of value in that.
Especially, with like the power of the NRA
and the people that
choose to try to advocate
for the rights of inanimate
objects over human beings,
they're so loud, and they
have such strong connection
to each other than the people
that are actually affected
mostly by those actions
that want people and kids to be protected
not weapons like an AR-15.
If you're alone, even though
we're actually in the majority
if you do a poll, the country in general,
that solidarity and friendship,
and community peace,
is extremely powerful
because it's that community
that enables social movements,
I believe in the longterm to succeed,
because at the core of
social movement power
and the core political
power isn't politics at all,
it's culture, it's
music, it's storytelling.
And it's only in those community spaces
when we're around each other,
that we're able to show love
and appreciation for each
other and care for each other,
even as unfortunately, no actions taken,
or even retroactive actions taken.
We're able to be there
at kind of as the bedrock
and endurance that is necessary
for the sustainability of the movement.
But when that community is only working
solely on the issue itself
and not really hanging out
and talking with each other,
that's when things come in.
And that's actually one thing
I realized, and did research,
that I did this semester,
it wasn't necessarily very scientific,
but it was just for a
history class of mine.
I was interviewing different
civil rights activists
that went to Harvard and worked
on like the freedom rights,
for example.
- Nice (indistinct).
- And one of them talked about how,
I won't say his name for privacy reasons,
but one of them talked about how,
when it was like ,I
think it was like 1963,
or something like that,
he went down to the south
to work on the freedom rights,
and he was meeting up with
like some young people
from the student non-violent
coordinating committee,
and everything, and he walked in the room
as a sophomore at Harvard, I think,
and he was expecting a ton of students
to be strategizing on a chalkboard
and like drawing all this stuff
out talking about policy and everything.
But he walked in and these
young civil rights activists
from all around the south, were
actually having a preach off
seeing who could imitate
MLK the best, and dancing,
and playing guitar, and singing together.
And one thing you told me is like,
"How could you see that and
not wanna be part of that?"
I think it's that community aspect
hanging out with each other, that music,
that really builds
successful social movements
in the long run.
Because ultimately,
leaders in social movements
can have their own
impacts in different ways,
but the real power in
those, it's in the culture,
and it's in the community,
because, some movements are ones
where everyone are leaders
in the first place,
where everybody is able to lead themselves
and take care of each other.
And when we're not doing that,
when we're not having fun,
it's not sustainable.
So that's been a big focus of myself
and the organization over
the past years figuring out
how can still cope with COVID,
but how can we celebrate our wins,
how can we take time to hang
out and do things not related
to incredibly exhausting
and traumatized work,
like trying to stop
people from getting shot.
- Yeah, it's so important.
I mean, the research backs us up too,
in terms of the psychology research
that's been done looking
at the power of community
even in terms of the
neuroscience research,
looking at what being a
community does to the brain
and how it helps with just
moving through stresses
and resilience, I think, I mean.
- Yeah, you're right.
- Everything you're saying
is spot on in a lot of ways.
How would you say you're cultivating that?
'Cause it seems like
there's two pieces there.
There's both kinds of
self-care, the daily self-care,
but then also making sure
there's the community self care,
making sure that those
are ingrained in a way.
- So I think one thing that
we are trying to do kind of,
is trying to develop some kind of system
to deal with the inevitable grievances
that come up between the
organizers and leaders
on an annual basis where
we just talk it out,
we talk about and move on.
But it's also...
The way that I practice it personally is
I just call up friends
randomly that I've worked with,
which, you know, some people
don't like being called,
or whatever, but I'll text them,
or I just like talking to them and stuff.
And I ask them, I basically,
at some point I checked in with them
and I just talked to him casually.
But really, it's a good
way of checking myself
to make sure I'm taking care of myself,
but it's a good way of
having accountability
for making sure other people
are taking care of themselves well.
So I think if we look
at the history of the civil
rights movement, unfortunately,
because of understandably the
incredible amount of trauma
and stuff behind it,
there's a lot of people...
We hear a lot about like
the successes of the leaders
and stuff in different everyday people
that have participated, where
we don't hear a lot about
is even, the people that ended up
abusing various substances, and
stuff because of the trauma,
and not being able to
deal with it and stuff.
And, I don't know how much of that you can
when it's that level of trauma,
I don't know how much of that
you can actually just deal
with through community.
But I think that's
something that we're trying
to develop in the organization.
But just personally, I
just call friends randomly
a lot of the time and checking
in with them and I'm like,
"Hey, so what are you doing
to take care of yourself?
What are you doing that
you love, that you enjoy?
And, how are you making sure
that you're not underwater,
basically, and taking on too much stuff
because we need people to
be here for decades to come,
possibly, and not just the next
two years, but the next 20,
or even longer, hopefully not,
but we we need to be prepared for that.
So I've found that that's a good way
of checking in with people because,
I think there's a bad
tendency that I still have
but not nearly as bad as I used to,
and I know a lot of other people
who've had in the organization in the past
where we'd only talk to each
other in moments of crisis,
or when you need to do like mobilize.
And when you have that
I think there comes to be an
association with each other
of really negative
feelings and grievances,
if you're only mobilizing after,
say another shooting happens
or something like that,
it's not healthy.
And by focusing on talking to each other
in a non-crisis times, it's
a good way of realizing
that we're on the same side here,
and it helps reduce those
like interpersonal conflicts,
and make sure that we're
taking care of ourselves,
which further helps to reduce
those interpersonal conflicts.
And it's just a good way
of forming relationships,
'cause ultimately, at
that core political hours,
I talked about in the past
here, I think it's culture,
but it's also that
community and the fabric,
like the the strings that
make up that community,
and we use it together are relationships.
And they're not relationships
that are just made
because we're only talking about work,
they're made because you
understand what's going on
with each other, what's going
on with each other's families,
what's going on with each
other's significant others,
or whatever, and going on personally,
and you're there to support them,
even if it's not work-related.
I think those are the
best type of activist,
community relationships are the ones
where they're not at their
core, they're not just to run,
"Okay, we need to do X thing."
It's around actually knowing
what's going on with each other
and understanding why we do this work,
and each other's motives,
and the challenges that
each of us uniquely face.
- Yeah, that's so true,
'cause then you have
that foundation too, like you said,
it's not just focused on the mobilizing,
or the trauma of this kinda
built throughout that.
Again, the research
would back that up too,
and there's so many
important pieces there.
I'm curious if you feel like
there's enough resources
in place to, 'cause I mean, one of the...
I don't do trauma work specifically,
but I know one of the things
that comes up quite a bit
is making sure that people really know
how to help other people
walk through that.
'Cause you get a lot of instances
where people don't know
how to handle that.
They have good intentions
but they're actually
just end up retraumatizing people.
I mean, we talked about
that before you gone,
it just even in terms of
some of the interviews
that you've done, and
how it kinda gets back
to that same thing over and over again.
So I wonder if you all have
even thought about that
in terms of the movement,
like do you feel like
there are more resources,
and obviously that's a
challenge if resources are thin.
Furthermore, resources
that should be in place
to help people actually
process that trauma
as they're engaged in the work
so that it's not, you know,
going into a place that just making it
that much more difficult,
even with good intentions,
but unintentionally.
- Right, yeah, I mean, I think that
we certainly have more resources
than we did in the past,
but it's not nearly enough.
I'm just talking about
the movement as a whole,
which includes March for Our Lives.
I think one of the difficulties is that
we're so focused on spending the money
on the work that needs to be done.
It can seem hard for us to justify it,
like, if we need to pay for a therapist,
or some kind of community
counselor or something.
Even though in my opinion,
like resources are severely lacking,
but honestly, the biggest
obstacle besides the NRA
to us actually being successful
I would say is our trauma,
and the divisions that it creates.
And It can be hard to justify to donors,
or people that just give a
small amount or whatever.
Spending a couple $1000, for example,
on helping reduce community trauma,
and all these things that sound very big,
but really are important.
- Yeah, they are.
- And managing better relationships
and how to do those trainings,
instead of spending that
money on registering
a couple 100 new voters,
or a couple 1000 new voters or whatever.
Even though the only reason why we...
The overall return on investment,
if that's really what
we're talking about here
is significantly more. If
we're able to do more work,
and get more volunteers and
develop a stronger community,
if we're able to deal
successfully with that trauma.
But I would say, that's one
of the difficult things,
is honestly, if I could I would,
if we had the money to do it,
and people were more accepting
of understanding the importance of that,
I would love to hire way more
HR people and not just HR,
but I don't know what term to come up with
that doesn't sound incredibly
vague, and like BS.
But I guess like people
that really help manage community wellness
and like developing proper protocols
between how to train people,
especially in the past year,
since George Floyd and
everything like talking...
It's difficult when there's kids
from all different communities,
all different races,
that oftentimes, you never
really worked together
in a social justice...
Remember, they might've gone
to school together, and stuff.
But the dynamics of
racial identity and trauma
in the United States, and talking about it
is something that a lot of,
to be completely honest,
just white kids do not understand at all.
It's something that I'm
still learning about,
if I'm being completely honest,
and I'm always trying to get better at it,
but it's not something we're born knowing.
Especially, and we
certainly don't learn it
from society or the media.
So, yeah, I don't think
we have necessarily
at all enough resources
to deal with that trauma,
unfortunately, 'cause it's hard
to justify, but it's needed.
And we have done some things around it.
We try to have like occasional, somewhat,
we try to give people
time off, have retreats,
and we try to be really affirming
of when people need to go on vacation,
and really celebrate that,
because like, this work is hard,
it's really hard, and our issue is not
that people don't wanna do the work,
it's that they wanna do too much.
- Yup, (laughs) I mean,
yeah, in a lot of ways,
you're talking about a cultural shift too.
Because some of those
resources are needed,
and I agree with you
that makes things better
in the long run, but it
doesn't look as shiny
if you're trying to raise them like,
it doesn't look as much of an investment,
'cause you can't see
that outcome right away.
- And they're telling it
- But unfortunately,
- on the news.
- Like you said, you can see
what happens when it's not addressed,
but-
- Right, yeah.
You know, unfortunately a lot of the work
that needs to be done in the organization
and in the social justice space
is not to end gun violence
or address the things
that play into gun violence;
like racial justice,
or environmental injustice,
or economic injustice,
are not things that necessarily get
on the news super easily.
For example, March this
year committed to a...
We have a half million dollar commitment
to grants and focus on
mutual aid, you know;
providing food, clothing,
whatever communities need,
and going specifically to the community,
the black and brown communities
that are most impacted by gun violence
asking them how we can be supportive
of the community
organizations like Life Camp,
I'm wearing their shirt right now,
doing the work on the ground,
stopping kids from shooting each other,
or everyday people from
shooting each other.
Instead of going to them and saying,
"This is what we're gonna do for you:
we're gonna throw $10,000 at you,
and you're just gonna be happy.
And like we did our job,
we're equitable or whatever."
We're gonna really ask
'cause we understand,
I don't know what goes on in,
for example, Jamaica, Queens,
where this shirt of LIFE
Camp that I've worked with,
I don't know what goes on there.
Erica Ford, who's been
doing this work for 20 years
in Jamaica, Queens and is stopping kids
from shooting each other every day.
She knows what needs to be done.
So we ask people like her,
"what can we do to be supportive?"
But even though there's a big commitment,
which is a significant part of our budget,
we're not like the NRA,
we don't have a $100,000,000 budget,
or whatever a year at all.
We get by, but it's still
nothing in comparison to that.
Even though there's that commitment
and the work that comes out of it,
it doesn't get on the news.
So it's hard because like
we know that that's the work
that needs to be done to actually be...
To help advance the movement forward,
but it's also difficult
because we know that
a lot of that money in comparison
to spending it on something
like, a big event or something,
it's not gonna get on the news,
but we know that that's the
work that needs to be done.
I think that's actually
a really big problem
with the nonprofit industrial complex,
if I'm being completely honest,
is that we have a system of incentives
that incentivize people to do
things that get on the news,
even if they're not necessarily effective.
I can't tell you the number of times
I've seen an organization spend six,
even seven figures on things
that could have been massively impactful,
for extremely under-resourced
community organizations,
and have a huge impact,
but they choose instead
to spend on something that's
gonna get on CNN, or whatever,
even though it's not gonna
have that much of an impact
in comparison to where that
money actually really could go.
So it's difficult, because
then we get questions like,
"Oh what is March for Our Lives doing?"
It's like, "Well, we're focused
on needs mutual aid programs.
We're focusing on talking about
what we call arms supremacy."
Like the role of guns in
white supremacist circles
and actions and the
enforcement of white supremacy
in the United States.
we're talking about mental health,
but not in a way where it's like,
"Let's talk about the mental health
and the shooter at my high school
and why you decided to do that."
And talk about that only
because he's a white kid.
And we tend to stereotype
white man shooters
as mentally ill because
we don't wanna talk
about the fact that they're a
lot of the time, not always,
but a significant amount
of the time it's simply,
I can't say simply, but it's
in large part if not entirely,
because they're racist.
The shooter at my high school
was racist and antisemitic.
He was known to have drawn
things like swastikas on stuff.
I don't see that racism and antisemitism
as mental illness.
But it's difficult because
we wanna talk about
mental health in regards to
the two-thirds gun deaths
that are suicides and don't
get on the news, right?
- Right.
- That's really what
needs to be addressed.
If we wanna talk about
addressing total gun deaths
we should be talking
two-thirds of the time
if not more about gun suicide.
But because the mental health conversation
is only around who a mass shooter is...
I cannot tell you I've had conversations
with poor kids that said
they were depressed.
So they went through the school counselor.
And the school counselor put
them on a list saying that
they were possible mass shooter
because they were depressed
and they were worried
about hurting themselves.
That is the effect that
the media is having
on these conversations.
And it's so hard because we can't...
Those conversations
around armed supremacy,
around mental health but
around suicide prevention,
and around mutual aid and racial justice
are not easy things to
fit in a soundbite like,
universal background checks,
which yes it can have an impact,
but ultimately, isn't it...
For a lot of cities that
have stronger gun laws,
although, there's certainly
a lack of federal ones,
a lot of these guns that
get there quite frankly,
get there illegally because there's a lack
of like federal guidance around
interstate gun trafficking
that could actually prevent it.
It's extremely hard to
get a gun in Chicago,
or it's not necessarily
as hard as it could be,
but it's still hard nonetheless,
you can just drive 30 minutes to Indiana,
and get a gun and come back,
or some guy can go and buy 50 guns
and sell them out of
the back of his truck,
legally, a lot of the time,
on the Salter west side,
and have them go out that way.
But what we need to address is,
why do people on this
ultimate side feel the need
to pick up a gun in the first place?
It's because they don't have resources.
Parkland has significantly
weaker gun laws than Chicago
than many other cities in the country.
We don't have shootings on a daily basis.
And it's not because we have
the most police officer,
or the most stringent gun laws,
it's because we had the most resources.
And having those conversations are not
that those nuances are extremely hard
to get across in a TV news interview.
It doesn't fit into the
neatly package, trauma,
industrial media complex
that commodifies these mass shootings
where they have graphics,
like it's some kinda
baseball game or something.
Where it's like, "This is how
many people you know, die.
This is how it compares
to other mass shootings
and things like that."
Without any regard to
the fact that most people
that are gonna die today from gun violence
are self-inflicted gunshot wounds.
They are unintentional shooting,
and they're everyday acts
of interpersonal gun violence
and domestic violence.
That's what needs to get
on the news but doesn't.
So it's simple, because what
we need to do is over here,
it's in one corner and we
know what we need to do,
but what actually enables
people to get a good like,
the nonprofit industrial complex
to get a return on investment
so they can continue doing the work
might be in a completely different space.
And there's plenty of people that do that,
and then we get people asking,
"Well, what are we doing?"
And the answer is we're
doing more work than we have,
and we're in the best
place the organization,
in my opinion, has ever been
in terms of sustainability.
But we're focusing on things that
the news doesn't typically like to cover.
- Yeah, 'cause that mean
you're doing the real work
that's not getting out there.
And like you said, I
mean, with the sound bites
so much of the truth gets lost too.
I mean, especially around the
mental health conversations
I mean, all the evidence
shows that those struggling
with mental health are much
more likely to be victims
of gun violence and perpetrators,
'cause somehow that continues
- Exactly.
- to get lost in the conversation.
- And-
- Yeah, go ahead.
- Those issues around funding,
or why we need more people to contribute,
we'll tell you about the
work that we do, it's just,
you're not gonna see it on CNN,
even though it's way more important
than the work that does get on CNN.
- Yeah, yeah, so, on that lines,
what do you see as your role?
'Cause, I mean, again,
there's that tension
which I think is just a
theme of a lot of the work
that you're doing, 'cause it's so;
one, it's such important work
and it's such a huge problem
but that tension is gonna
be in a lot of ways.
But how do you balance
between what you're doing
on the ground that you
know is making an effect
and making a difference,
versus what's getting
the air time in a sense.
Not that the air time is important.
In some ways the airtime
could help galvanize
the work that's being done.
So, I mean, if you all
have those conversations
if you're trying to wrestle with that.
- Yeah, I mean, it's difficult.
I think what we try to do is
we try to make the organization
more faceful instead of faceless,
if that makes sense?
- Mm-hm.
And we're trying to show the other leaders
in the organization that
may not be from Parkland,
but nonetheless, I would
consider almost like co-founders
of different marches around the country.
One of them is like a
board member of mine,
a fellow youth board member of mine
who just graduated college
and is now a Truman scholar,
named Daud Mumin
He's done a ton of work
in gun violence prevention
in Salt Lake city.
And, we tried to get him on
the news but it's difficult
when news one wants to why he...
They want to put us in a box
of like mainly white Parkland
students, and just that's it.
When in reality, we realize
in order to make this movement
our contribution to the movement,
'cause we're by no means the movement,
but to make our contribution
to the movement successful
and as impactful as it can be,
it has to go beyond the
the border of Parkland,
it has to be all encompassing
at the United States.
And it's difficult because it's harder
to tell a story in that way
because there's so many
different communities,
and there's so many different solutions
that have to be talked about.
But we realize that that's
really the only right
that can be done.
The other thing that I do is
when I'm doing interviews, for example,
yesterday I was on MSNBC and they're like,
"How are you David?"
And I went something like,
"I cared about that."
Answer is, "I'm not great.
Honestly, I don't think
anyone that's gone through
an instance of gun violence
is ever really great,
ever again."
But what I always tried to
do is I try to redirect it,
towards people like Erica,
that've been in Jamaica, Queens,
that have been doing this work
for basically over 20 years.
at this point and are
having a massive impact.
It's talking about people like pastor Mike
that work with groups like
LIVE FREE and Faith in Action
out in Oakland, California,
that are doing a real work,
on the ground, in the cities
and violence interrupters.
To redirect the conversation
towards them, and I also see...
'Cause I'm able to get
into a lot of these rooms
because of my profile, or the
fact that I'm a white guy,
and these rooms even though
the majority of people
that are affected by gun violence
tend to be black and brown,
I see my role as helping open not...
I hate this idea of a table,
'cause there shouldn't
be a table to begin with,
because that's like a
whole power structure.
But what I see it as
it's trying to kinda like
step back and put people in my place,
or I guess help expand
the table in some way,
or I've lost track of the
metaphor by this point,
but you know what I mean?
- Yeah, I do.
- Like I'm trying you use my position
to basically bring in people like Erica,
a lot of the times
integrating these people,
about like not being inclusive,
not doing these things properly, it works,
because of meetings that I've had before
other organizations, or
other coalition groups
that were almost not entirely white,
but were almost entirely white.
If we're in New York city and
we're having a giant meeting,
30 storeys up in some building,
but I know Erica is in Jamaica Queens
doing this work and
she's not in that room,
and no one like Erica is in that room,
that's a problem.
- Exactly.
- Right, so I see it as helping to...
I don't know, I don't like
when people like shine a light
on other communities, but I'm trying
to expand the spotlight,
to include the communities
I've been doing this work for
decades that have to organize
not because they want to
because it's for their survival,
it's for their literal
survival that they do.
Activism is not optional for many people,
for the majority of real
activists that are out there,
it is not optional.
They have to do it for the community
their own survival or
their community's survival.
So that's why I see my role as,
is trying to acknowledge the
amount of power that I have
in this position that quite frankly,
much of which is because
of the work that I've done,
but also a large amount of it
is because I'm a white guy,
and recognizing that the
responsibility that power carries
to acknowledge that and expand it to in,
or not expand it, but
just, highlight the work
that it's been doing for, and
show respect to the people
that have been doing the
work for decades before me.
And with that power also use
it to challenge other parts
of the disproportionately white piece
at the national gun violence
prevention organizations,
to challenge them to
actually focus on things
that aren't just around gun
control, although it's needed,
but talk about violence
intervention programs.
And because of things like that,
Erica Ford and pastor Mike and others,
were at the White House
in the Rose garden.
And Biden upped his commitment
in our initial kinda peace
plan that we came up with.
I think we demanded a billion dollars,
over several years or something
to violence intervention programs.
And because of the work
that the community justice
action funding Amber Goodwin
and others had been doing
around them and in that space.
I believe because part of
the March for Our Lives
challenging these other organizations
by having the work that
these orgs have been doing
for way before any of us were here,
Bidden upped his commitment
to $5 billion a year,
or not by a billion dollars
a year to $5 billion
over like eight years to these programs
that aren't policing based
but are public health based
and can actually help communities
in the first place by
providing trauma services
and reduce retaliation and resources.
- Nice, that's on you.
- And that's why I see my role,
is helping to challenge that dynamic.
I'm by no means perfect,
I still fuck up a lot.
But I try to do the best that I can
and acknowledge what I do,
continue to work through it.
- I mean, I think that's great.
I mean, it's a holistic
approach in a lot of ways,
'cause, I keep using the word tension
but I feel like it's all there.
'Cause I mean, you've done the
work like that carries weight
but then you also know there's privilege,
which he didn't
- Yeah,
- necessarily earn,
- there's a lot of it.
There's a lot-
- So, I mean,
you're bringing those together,
you're still making sure
that people who have been doing the work
on the ground are acknowledged.
And so I think in a lot of
ways what you're talking about
is walking alongside them, and
I think that's important too.
- I really see it as like-
- And you're not saying
I'm here being the one to kinda save you
from your whatever X, Y, and
Z, but I'm learning from you.
I'm gonna walk through it with
you and come alongside you,
I'm gonna bring you where I am.
- Yeah, and that's really the
approach that I try to take.
When I've worked with Erica
in the past, for example,
I just happened to be in New
York for different meetings
and stuff, and I was like,
I have a couple of days off,
or whatever, I'm gonna
spend it working with you.
And I'm like, so, Erica
has seen me as an intern.
like if you want water,
I I'm here to learn,
I'm just here to observe.
You want water, I'll get you water,
you want coffee, I'll get you coffee.
I'll be like, you literally
using it whatever way you want.
I just wanna observe and
learn truly the best.
So I don't even see it as
walking alongside them.
I see it as walking behind them.
And seeing them lead and learning
from the different paths
that they've taken them
of how I can be supportive
in that in the first place
and highlight the work that they're doing
for lack of a better word.
All these words, there's
such a power dynamic,
and they're so loaded, like
uplift, shine the spotlight,
because it like, there's such a...
I don't like the power dynamic
that's within that vernacular
because it's not the power
dynamic that like is productive
to this conversation 'cause it comes
from like a white saviorist
place like that vernacular
is not only white saviorist place
but also a white supremacist place
in the first place that implies a sense
of entitlement and a belief
that you know more about
what to do for someone's
community, than the people
that actually live in that
community know what to do.
So it's difficult to talk about.
But honestly, I just try to
lead with humility and ask,
how I can be supportive
as much as possible
while acknowledging that, I
do screw up from time to time,
but trying to learn from those things
and be forgiving of
myself too, which is hard,
especially with the kind of
culture that we have on Twitter
and social media that is not forgiving
a lot of the times.
- Not forgiving at all.
Which again, is completely
unrealistic as I'm sure you know.
Especially, I mean, this goes back
to the first part of our conversation,
with everything that
you've gone through already
and everything that you're doing,
perfection is always unrealistic.
But when you put all those
pieces together, I mean
we talked about this too,
just about the trauma.
It's just not even a
healthy place to start.
So I know we're still back to kinda this,
there's a huge cultural shift
that we need to have in a lot of ways.
And, in some ways I think
hopefully COVID has helped
with that, right, and COVID
has not been a good thing
by any stretch of the imagination.
But I think in some ways
it's helped people realize
how a lot more of us react
under stress and uncertainty
and knowing that, okay,
there needs to be some room
for forgiveness when
things get smashed in.
And when people are in the
middle of work after trauma
you need to have that
grace and forgiveness
to be able to move through things and say,
okay are things really getting addressed?
Or you putting these
standards on people to
go a thousand miles an hour
and hit unrealistic goals.
And then if they have any little
falter, then you just come
down the hard when you're not even driving
through it yourself.
- And I mean, my thing is too that,
if if the movement can't be,
if we're too pure for ourselves
how are we ever gonna
have other people join in
right. When, like the
way that we learn a lot
of the time as these mistakes,
unfortunately, exactly.
It doesn't mean that there
is no accountability.
There should be.
Yeah. But there needs to be, a demand
not just for accountability
but true growth and
learning because that's the
only way that these
things become successful.
I think that actually plays into the
a bigger thing around how, although yes
our government has a
much bigger role to play
and in ending gun violence
and passing these laws
and helping fund these programs.
There's also a cultural
role that we need to have
a reevaluation, why are we as a country,
so obsessed with machines
made to kill people,
that's what they are, right.
Why do we romanticize
violence, and stigmatize,
so many other things that are not
like that, and it's, I
I think it goes into not
just a cultural aspect
because the way I see ending
gun violence is it's like
I think about a third of
it is like the gun laws.
I think a third of it is
like different things
about how do we stop people
from wanting guns in the first place.
But another third is the
cultural aspect that we have to
we have to acknowledge the fact
that although our government is corrupt
in a number in, in many ways
ultimately our government
is a product of not all
of us because of rampant, voter
suppression, but many of us.
And it is a reflection of
our values as a society
as a society, we need to either reaffirm
or change some of what
we truly reprioritize
what we truly do value,
in order to do that.
And I think that that comes
down to a whole conversation
too, around justice and not
I truly believe that if we
want to end gun violence
gun violence, we need
to acknowledge that gun
violence is a symptom of injustice.
If we don't address that injustice
if we can't make a, an unjust country
we'll never be a piece of
country, a peaceful country ever.
And we have to talk about
that, those resources
and the systemic injustice
that causes this gun violence
in the first place, even
though it's not easy
to fit into a soundbite
it really is the only way
we're ever gonna end this
in the first place.
- Yeah. That's so well said
so important and you're right.
I mean, it's not easy.
I think that's part
of the challenge that you
all are trying to deal with.
Head-on so, I mean
I'm encouraged to hear
about the organization,
still thriving in a lot of ways
even outside of the public
eye, in a sense, and some
of the structures that been
put in place, especially
around the delegation,
especially around the self care
because again, I think that's important
for the life or for the
organization and life.
You also, the life of the community
and the life of the communities
that are doing this work.
I would imagine,
those you've mentioned them
in the news for 20 plus years.
Those pieces have to be in place
in some shape or form
with the community piece
and the self care otherwise,
with everything that
they're and we're already
into is just not, not
gonna be sustainable.
- I mean, it's a big focus
of the organization too.
Part of the reason why that
the media is lagging and stuff,
is we realized, as I said in the past,
previously to that stuff that gets on CNN
isn't necessarily what ends us,
but we're focused on doing
more and saying less.
'Cause ultimately like the
time that we spend talking,
it's time that we could be
spending registering voters,
it's time that we could
be helping raise money
for community organizations
and building coalitions,
instead of competing against
other nonprofits and stuff,
which I think is a horrible product
of the hyper capitalistic nonprofit,
industrial complex that has been developed
around treating symptoms like gun violence
instead of addressing
causes of gun violence
in the first place.
But, it's all the more
reason why we need people
to help fund us, because we
may not be getting on CNN,
but we're registering voters,
we're doing the real work.
And we've seen the product to
that the past couple years.
- Yeah, that's really encouraging to hear.
And I appreciate taking us
through the journey too,
even in terms of from the beginning
and where you are now.
One thing I do wanna do before we wrap up
though is just in terms of
folks who might be listening
who are saying, "Okay, I
want to know more about
either what's going on in my
community, or how I can help
with some of these more
national initiatives.
Like where, where would you direct people
in terms of really making
an impactful difference
and not just going for
the the shine factor,
or tokenism or anything else like that?
- Yeah, I think, the best thing
that you could probably do
in general, where there's a
lot of resources available
is just going to the March
for Our Lives website.
It's just March for Our Lives,
like marchforourlives.com,
and there you can register
to vote, if you're not,
but you can also text our
954-954 four text code
that can let about
local events, elections,
and things like that.
That our chapters and coalitions
are working on in your area.
And you can see a lot of
the work that March is doing
that may not necessarily
be getting on CNN,
but it's even more important
than the stuff that gets on the news.
So yeah, that's really what I would say.
And, just try to do as
much as you can at minimum
try to make it voting if
you have the privilege,
because unfortunately voting
is not a right in this country.
I would argue for many people
that have been incarcerated
but if you have that ability to vote
please do so at the minimum,
and if you're able to do more,
try to do more.
Get involved with local
community organizations,
just look up like gun violence
prevention organization,
or whatever in your city,
if you're in New York,
LIFE Camp is a great one
that I would suggest.
There in Jamaica, Queens,
there's also Save our Streets
in the Bronx, there's Live Free
and Faith in Action in Oakland,
in the San Francisco area,
in Los Angeles, I'm trying
to think of what it's called,
I forgot, there's a
number of organizations,
there's a lot of organizations
that do work in LA too
that you can look up.
Yeah, just try to figure
out how to get involved,
and even, even if it's
just in a small manner,
just do it consistently.
Even if it's just voting, try
to vote in every election,
even if it's just, trying to volunteer,
help out in any way, or
working on a campaign
of a candidate that you know,
really runs on gun violence prevention,
we need more people to do that,
because we don't we have the disadvantage
of not having several
hundred million dollars,
like the NRA does, but
we have the advantage
of having way more people
that support us in general.
But we need those people
to be much more out there
because the NRA is a
extremely loud but effective,
they're an extremely small,
but extremely loud and effective minority.
And if we could just figure out
how to get a small
percentage of our country
mobilized around this issue,
we easily end it in 10
years or less, way less.
- Well, I appreciate you
sharing all those resources
and all that great advice.
I mean, there's so many
different opportunities
to be able to really
jump in and do the work
that needs to be done.
And the work is already
being done on a lot of ways,
so I appreciate you
coming on the "Addy Hour"
and taking us through, I mean,
we covered a lot of ground,
so a lot of important ground
but really appreciate it,
kind of sharing the journey and
what you have going forward,
and continue to wish you the
best in this important work,
especially, the work that's
not getting their play.
I mean, I think that's where
the real work is being done
in a lot of ways, but hopefully,
with some of these pieces
things will continue to get countenance.
Glad you're taking care of yourself too,
I mean, as we've talked about that-
- Well, thanks for having
me on, I appreciate it.
- Yeah, it's been great.
(upbeat hiphop music)